pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
l'hôte blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors les européens ont envie de voyager
évidemment cet été profiter de quelques
jours de vacances comment concilier la
politique de tous ces pays qui n'ont pas
été impactées info le rappeler de la
même manière par par cette crise
oui en effet les pays européens ont
réagi en ordre dispersé en fonction de
leur évaluation de la menace de l'état
de leur système sanitaire
et puis de la façon dont ils
appréhendaient les mouvements de
population avec l'extérieur
alors aujourd'hui on a en effet deux
deux systèmes qui ce qui coïncide d'une
part shingen mais schengen est un
système qui d'une part comporte des
états qui ne sont pas membres de l'union
européenne comme la norvège et la suède
et d'autre part certains états membres
de l'union européenne ne se commandent
de schengen comme par exemple la
roumanie ou la bulgarie alors schengen
c'est un système en fait qui est touche
à la frontière extérieure et la
frontières extérieures de schengen en
effet est tout à fait établi et pour se
protéger des afflux de personnes venant
venant de l'extérieur de cette de cette
zone les états membres quand ils sont
pris quand ils ont pris des mesures de
confinement quand ils ont pris des
mesures de restriction d'arrivée de
d'étrangers ont fait jouer l'article 23
et l'article 28 de la convention de
schengen qui prévoit en effet que en cas
d'urgence sanitaire en cas de de
situation extrêmement grave et bien un
état peut prendre des mesures
conservatoires et il peut fermer ses
frontières
il peut le faire pour un mois
renouvelable dans la limite de deux ans
ceci laisse du temps et j'espère bien
que les frontières sont ouvertes avant
et en deuxième lieu le système
communautaire l'union européenne dans
laquelle comme vous le savez la libre
circulation des personnes est un élément
essentiel comme la libre circulation des
les marchandises comme la libre
circulation des capitaux et là dessus
aussi
les états membres se sont mis en
exception compte tenu de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et chacun a pris ces
mesures
naturellement en en parlant à la
commission et en se concertant si
possible avec ses voisins pour ce qui
est de la france présente la république
a dit lundi une fois de plus très
clairement que bien entendu il faut
rétablir la liberté de circulation à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
bien entendu il faut rétablir la liberté
de circulation à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen mais bien entendu dans le
respect d une réciprocité entre chacun
des états avec la france autrement dit
si l'italie maintien des restrictions
vis-à-vis de la france
eh bien la france maintiendra les mêmes
restrictions vis-à-vis vitaly si
l'italie maintien si l'espagne maintien
des restrictions vis-à-vis de la france
eh bien la france maintiendra les mêmes
restrictions vis-à-vis de l'espagne
pendant le temps où cela durera alors il
ya des négociations bilatérales en effet
avec tous ces pays il y en a eu avec
l'allemagne et ceci a déjà donné des
résultats puisque les travailleurs
frontaliers ont pu maintenance en
difficulté peuvent rejoindre leur
travail chaque jour
et effectivement je crois que la
concertation la plus forte se fait avec
l'allemagne mais elle se fait aussi par
les voies diplomatiques avec chacun des
autres états membres de l'union
européenne et de la zone schengen donc
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
la situation sanitaire s'améliorait et
bien d'ici quelques semaines au pire
quelques mois la liberté de circulation
à l'intérieur de la zone schengen sera
rétablie mais je pense que les
frontières extérieures resteront fermés
ou en tout cas très surveillée pour
longtemps alors que blanche maison
l'union européenne semble sortir
affaibli rendent cette crise du
coronavirus difficile effectivement de
s'entendre entre chefs d'état parfois
chaque pays va être impactée par cette
crise qu'on nous annonce
n'y at il pas un risque de repli sur soi
comment la solidarité européenne
peut-elle continuer d'exister
oui l'urgence sanitaire a fait que en
effet chaque pays s'est concentré sur
lui-même mais c'est dû au fait aussi que
les père fondateur de l'union européenne
ont très spécifiquement exclu la santé
du traité de rome et que leurs
successeurs dans tous les traités qu'on
peut avoir lieu masse riche lisbonne et
d'autres ont aussi exclu a santé par
conséquent la santé reste la compétence
essentiellement national mais comme ça a
été dit par la chancelière et par le
président français lundi dernier sans
changer les traités
on peut faire un certain nombre de
choses ensemble on pourrait par exemple
avoir une agence commune d'évaluation de
la situation sanitaire
on pourra avoir des stocks communs
d'urgence en matière sanitaire de
produits médicaux et même de médicament
et puis surtout on peut financer en
commun la recherche pour trouver des
vaccins et des délais et des médicaments
alors pour le reste tous les états
membres constate aujourd'hui que le
confinement a fait la démonstration de
ce que l'on savait c'est à dire que si
on ferme les frontières
si en plus en même temps l'appareil
économique s'arrête et bien il ya une
formidable récession économique qui se
met en place
donc aujourd'hui ce qui est à l'ordre du
jour c'est la remise en marche des
appareils de production et de l'appareil
de commerciaux nationaux mais aussi des
échanges à l'intérieur des états membres
parce que évidemment l'imbrication des
économies européennes fait que son
réouverture des frontières et bien
chaque pays perdrait un certain nombre
de ses clients de ses ses marchés il ya
donc urgence à faire repartir l'économie
et c'est pour cela que en effet des
états membres de l'union européenne
doivent coordonner leurs mesures sur le
plan économique alors l'écran et angela
merkel ont présenté un plan solidaire un
plan de relance à 500 milliards d'euros
je vous propose avant de le commenter
d'écouter la chancelière allemande
nous voulons avoir un fonds qui soit
bien sûr limité dans le temps mais 500
milliards d'euros sont prévus il ne
s'agirait pas de crédit il s'agirait de
dépenses budgétaires qui serait
attribuée au secteur et aux régions les
plus touchées par l'aco vide
nous sommes convaincus que ces mesures
sont justifiées qu'elles sont
nécessaires
il est important que l'union européenne
mette de l'argent à disposition
et ça pendant plusieurs années il faudra
bien sûr rembourser cet argent
alors évidemment on retiendra comme
blanchemaison cette dernière phrase il
faudra rembourser cet argent c'est ce
que nous dit angela merkel sait ce qui
va pousser les européens à davantage de
solidarité entre eux oui parce que la
mécanique semble un peu complexe en
réalité elle est très simple elle
consiste à donner à donner à l'union
européenne à travers la commission la
possibilité de lever sur les marchés
financiers 500 millions d'euros pour
financer ensuite par des dotations
budgétaires du budget européen
les régions et les secteurs peut-être là
des entreprises qui ont été les plus
impactés et puis ensuite les états
membres rembourseront à une science qui
reste à déterminer je pense que
l'emprunt sera fait à 10 ans au moins à
10 ans et que par conséquent c'est à cet
escient ce que se pose le problème du
remboursement et ce ne sont pas les
bénéficiaires entreprises aux régions de
débit notation budgétaire d'urgence
décidée par la commission
ils rembourseront ce sont les états
membres et ils rembourseront suivant une
clé qui reste à négocier et il sera très
vraisemblablement très proche de la clé
budgétaires actuelles c'est-à-dire pour
l'allemagne la chancelière a cité le
chiffre de 27 % dans les faits entre 27
et 29 et 25 et 27% et pour la france
c'est aux environs de 17 à 18%
mais ceci reste à négocier puisque la
semaine prochaine
exactement dans une dent d'une semaine
la commission doit faire une proposition
une proposition dans l'ensemble qui
comportera des précisions sur tous les
mécanismes et ya fort à parier que
probable qu'elle prendra en effet pour
une bonne partie les propositions franco
allemandes mais qu'elle y ajoutera
beaucoup de choses et il ya fort à
parier que à côté de ce qui doit faire
l'objet de dotation budgétaire donc de
dons elle mettra en place également des
cités système de prêt et c'est
d'ailleurs le apparemment le schéma sur
lequel
vas y et surtout auparavant donc il ya
différents canaux par lesquels la
commission peut aussi envisager un
système de prêt aux régions et aux
secteurs les plus impactés par la crise
et ceci viendrait compléter le schéma
qui a été décidé par pas décidé proposé
par la france et par l'allemagne
bien sûr reste à décider pour quels
montants pour l'un et pour l'autre
merci avons claude blanchemaison pour
cet éclairage complet